let's take a quick tour through
appearances on right-wing media and by
republican politicians over the last 24
hours or so the big news of course we
covered it at the top of the show
with that with absolutely zero
republican support in the senate
democrats passed a 1.9 trillion dollar
stimulus bill
which while not as big as we want not as
soon as we wanted doesn't include the
minimum wage
it will put thousands of dollars in the
pockets of families with
children it will provide a ton of money
to accelerate vaccination
and it was all done without a single
republican supporting it a great
question for these republican elected
officials would be
you know a lot of your constituents want
this bill and yet you voted against it
that was not the story on right wing
media for the 24
for the last 24 hours what is the right
been up to over this period of time
let's take a look first example here is
mississippi governor tate reeves
who recently cancelled all coveted
guidelines wide open state no more
masking nothing
tate reeves went on cnn and still
in nearly the middle of march would not
acknowledge that
joe biden simply won the election
take a look at this do you accept that
joe biden
is the legitimate lawfully accepted
lawfully elected president of the united
states
president biden is the president of the
united states
was he legitimate mail in voting
in our state we do not allow mail in
voting and the reason we don't allow
mail in voting is because we don't think
um that it we think that it allows for
lots of opportunities for fraud and
other things
and i don't think melon voting should be
allowed in other states around the
nation but
president biden is the the duly elected
president and we're going to do
everything we can to work with him
to help the citizens of mississippi
there are lots of states
that trump won where there's mail-in
voting including florida
including ohio including utah i hear you
saying joe biden is the president i do
not hear you saying
he was legitimately elected fbi director
chris wray former attorney general bill
barr
have both stated there was no widespread
voter fraud none that could have
affected the outcome of the november
election
republican after republican ducey in
arizona
kemp in georgia your colleagues judge
after judge have rejected this rejected
this argument
this is a dangerous conspiracy theory
that tens of millions of people believe
it inspired a domestic terrorist attack
on the capitol
yes or no do you accept that the 2020
presidential election
was free and fair obviously every
election has some questions but i'm
talking about
free and fair legitimately elected joe
biden yes or no
as you said jake every election has some
questions and this one was no different
president biden is the duly elected
president of the united states that he
was
certified by all 50 states either having
won or lost he lost my state
by 20 points but he was certified in
each of the individual states he was
certified by the u.s congress and he's
the newly elected president all right
but that doesn't mean that we don't have
bad laws in the books
in other states it's just a fact this is
their new refrain
when asked they say joe biden
is the president that is very different
than joe biden actually won
they are still going with this they
can't simply say
uh despite always having some anecdotal
individual allegations of irregularities
in every election
the number of alleged irregularities
wouldn't come every anywhere close even
if they were all proven to be true
to affecting who won and yes of course
joe biden won he says that well
oh you know i mean listen joe biden is
president but there were irregularities
and
it's four months guys it's four months
and if they're still saying it now
they aren't going to stop anytime soon i
expect them to continue with this
all the way through to the 2024
presidential election and in fact
they'll use it to try to justify
continuing to suppress the vote
as we already see them doing more than
250 republican bills
in more than 40 states making it harder
to
vote so let's continue our tour
of what has been happening with
republicans and right-wing media
over the last day or two while democrats
were passing coveted relief
over on maria bartoromo's fox news show
she invited on senator lindsey graham
to talk about of course trans women
in sports hey listen at least it's not
dr seuss here's lindsey graham
away with a distinction between being a
man and woman in the law
uh biological boys are going to start
playing in girls sports
and if your religious organization out
there and your faith dictates that
certain things happen
this bill takes that ability now i've
talked about how trans women in sports
is a calculated fabricated issue
that does exist but affects
almost no one statistically but
also this idea from lindsay about the
laws are going to make our religious
beliefs irrelevant
they are the opposite of our religious
beliefs
who cares that's america we have
separation of church and state
you can privately believe whatever you
want
but you don't get to point to your holy
book and say
this belief of mine from my chosen
religion
dictates what the law should be if you
believe in
zeus if you're a a hellenist and you
showed up and you said
we must be allowed to do animal
sacrifices that's in our beliefs if you
don't allow that you're limiting our
ability to practice religion
civil law and government don't have to
allow that sorry guys you might believe
that but we have secular government no
can do
secular government shouldn't care what
your supposed holy book
says then one more from maria bartoromo
she casually mentions that we know covid
came from a chinese lab
and of course we we don't know that take
a listen oh i haven't also
heard president biden say anything about
where the coronavirus originated we know
it originated in a wuhan lab
imagine that she's criticizing biden
for not having said where the virus came
from
first why does biden have to weigh in on
that he's the president he's not a
scientist the virus has been around now
since you know november december of 2019
in some way shape or form
why does joe biden need to weigh in on
that on that and secondly of course
we don't know that it originated in a
chinese lab that's maria
repeating it as fact when it is not fact
and then lastly again as democrats were
passing coveted relief
here is radical republican trumpian
congresswoman lauren bobert
on fox news trying to make the case that
i guess what she's saying
is that undocumented immigrants are
drunk driving
and then not being punished or something
like that
schools they want to jail you for not
wearing a mask but want to keep illegal
aliens who are
i don't know drunk driving here in our
country
lauren beaubert who we'll talk about
more in a moment clearly not
understanding how immigration law works
in many states and jurisdictions if you
are drunk driving and you are arrested
local police don't conduct immigration
investigations local police if you're
drunk driving
deal with the drunk driving whether you
are here illegally or not they don't
involve themselves in that
the the the idea of they want to keep
them
in the country couldn't be more
deceptive
and dishonest so that's right-wing media
during the weekend
a weekend in which we scaled up
vaccination and did nearly eight million
doses in three days
past 1.9 trillion in covet stimulus in
the senate which now goes back to the
house
this is what they focused on what value
do they provide
what are they bringing to the table it
seems as though it's nothing but it's
actually something very important
they are providing a parallel agenda
setting
that is useful to those who want to
continue living
in this alternate reality and they don't
you know biden most popular initial
approval of any president in 30 years
people want coveted relief and it passed
people increasingly want the vaccines
and they're scaling them up you need a
parallel story to tell
and increasingly it's a story about
trans women in sports
cancel culture and undocumented
immigrants that's the story they've done
and now let's talk a little bit more
about
lauren bober